hey guys it is the 22nd of september's
today my name is Jess and here's what
mattered in gaming Warner Brothers have
released a patch from Mortal Kombat X
which includes a bunch of different
character tweaks the update is available
now on PlayStation 4 and the publishers
have said that it will make its way to
Xbox one and PC shortly the changes are
mostly character specific adjustments
which are being implemented to eliminate
bugs and improve overall game balance
for the full list of patch notes you can
head to our story on gamespot warner
brothers have previously said that
mortal kombat x will receive more dlc
next year in the form of additional
characters skins and a new environment
warner brothers had a busy day today as
they also detailed the new dlc coming to
batman arkham knight entitled Catwoman's
revenge in october the publisher is
releasing the batman classic TV series
mobile pack which includes classic skins
for the Batmobile Catwoman and Robin as
well as to TV inspired racetracks
Catwoman's revenge will arrive alongside
this pack the DLC is set after the
events of Arkham Knight and you'll play
as Catwoman who is seeking her avenged
on Riddler the third crime fighter
challenge pack is also due out in
October while the second challenge pack
as well as JCP f lockdown which will
cast you as Nightwing facing off against
the penguin are available on sep tember
29 the arkham knight season pass is
priced at 40 bucks finally hit man has
been delayed from december of this year
to march 2016 IO Interactive have said
that the delay will let the studio
expand what's available at launch the
game is being released digitally with a
portion of the complete experience after
which more episodes will be added the
studio explained these few extra months
will mean we can add more to the launch
content of the game more than we
originally had planned and then follow
with a tighter frequency of updates
which ultimately will create a better
game for everyone Square Enix have said
that they are experimenting with the
business model but want to assure game
is that they will not be
microtransactions
this will be a polished triple a hitman
game let me know down in the comments
how you feel about the Hitman delay and
be sure to head to gamespot where we've
got stories on fallout floors music and
a dragon age inquisition game of the
year edition that is everything I have
for you today as always let me know what
you cared about and I will catch you
same time tomorrow